[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHERINE MILLER: Hi, Nikhil.
It's great to see you here
at Google Cloud Next 2018.
Good event so far, for you?
NIKHIL KAUL: So far, so good.
And great to see you, Katie.
KATHERINE MILLER: It's
great to see you, as well.
I'm actually really
excited to be here
to learn more about
CI/CD with GCP.
NIKHIL KAUL: Ah,
great question, Katie.
So what we are
doing over here is
we are using Google Cloud
Platform's tools, specifically
developer tools, to create
a continuous integration
and a continuous
delivery pipeline.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
NIKHIL KAUL: So the tools
which you are seeing over here
specifically target three
specific areas, which
is storing your source
code, creating a build
and testing it, and then,
essentially, deploying it.
KATHERINE MILLER:
So can you show me
what demo you've built to walk
us through those three steps?
NIKHIL KAUL: Yeah, but
before I go over there,
let me take a step back and
tell you more about the demo.
KATHERINE MILLER: Sure thing.
Yeah.
NIKHIL KAUL: So in the demo,
what we are doing over here
is, we're really creating a
easy way for our attendees
to understand how you can
set up a CI/CD pipeline,
in a really easy-to-do fashion.
So what you will see
is, we will start
from writing code
and storing it.
Now, we will obviously
not be writing code.
To write code, we will
be actually pressing
the red button to do it.
KATHERINE MILLER: Wouldn't
it be nice, though,
if writing code was as simple
as pushing a red button?
NIKHIL KAUL: Obviously,
I would really like that.
So similarly, when the
code has been written,
we will create a
build and test it,
using our offering which we
recently released at Next,
which is called Cloud Build.
Once it has been built,
we will deploy it to,
depending upon which
environment you want,
whether you want to deploy
to on-prem whether you
wanted to deploy to Cloud.
We support both.
KATHERINE MILLER: OK.
Excellent.
NIKHIL KAUL: So let's
walk you through the demo.
KATHERINE MILLER: Yeah, let's
get started and see this demo.
NIKHIL KAUL: Let's
start with the demo.
So the first and
the foremost screen,
which you see on the
screen, is, where
do you want to store
your source code?
GitHub and Bitbucket, probably,
you might be familiar with.
But Google itself comes with--
Google has an offering, which
is called its Cloud Source
Repositories, which
is a private Git repo.
We see our customers using
Cloud Source Repositories
for two specific use cases.
One, it comes with
built-in integrations
to GCP tools, and second,
specifically with integrations
to Stackdriver.
It gives you really good
debugging capabilities,
since Cloud Source Repositories
has built-in integrations
with Stackdriver.
So for today's demo
purposes, let's say
our source code is going to
be stored in Cloud Source
Repositories.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
OK.
NIKHIL KAUL: As I
said, what we'll
do is, we'll click
the red button.
And then it goes into
writing the code phase.
As you can see, we are really
not writing the code over here,
manually.
What we are doing is
clicking the red button
and playing the slot machine.
KATHERINE MILLER: OK.
NIKHIL KAUL: So as we do it four
times, the code gets written.
The next step, obviously,
is creating the build.
So we have something called
as Cloud Build, which
is a CI/CD platform, which lets
you create both containers as
well as non-container
specific builds.
KATHERINE MILLER: OK
NIKHIL KAUL: The
three differentiators
for Cloud Build, specifically,
are scalability--
as you start ramping up your
builds across different team
members and different
projects, it still
gives you fast feedback
in a CI environment.
The second is security.
As we will see in the
next part of the demo,
it comes with built-in
vulnerability scanner.
And the third part of this Cloud
Build, which differentiates us,
is the flexibility piece.
So for the biggest part
of flexibility is it
comes with a YAML file.
And it lets you define
build steps specifically
for building the containers or
even non-container artifact,
testing it, and deploying it.
How is the demo so far, Katie?
KATHERINE MILLER: So far-- oh.
Something failed.
NIKHIL KAUL: Something failed.
And probably, that's because
I wrote some unit tests.
KATHERINE MILLER: All right.
NIKHIL KAUL: And they found
some flaws in my build.
KATHERINE MILLER: OK
NIKHIL KAUL: So the
next step, obviously,
is fixing those flaws.
And guess what?
How we are going
to fix those flaws?
Again, by pressing the
red button over here.
KATHERINE MILLER: Of course.
NIKHIL KAUL: Right.
KATHERINE MILLER: If only
life was this easy, right?
NIKHIL KAUL: Absolutely.
So right now, you will
see in the background,
Cloud Build
[INAUDIBLE] the build.
The build will take 10
to 15 seconds to build.
And we can see, on the
screen, the progress bar.
Once the build gets created,
you can see the build results,
the build time, the build queue
time, the worker startup time,
data transfer rate,
and other things.
But at this point of time, you
have stored your source code.
You have created a build.
There's one piece still
missing, the security piece.
KATHERINE MILLER: Right.
NIKHIL KAUL: Right.
You still need to ensure
the build which you just
created does not have any
security vulnerabilities.
So Cloud Build comes with
vulnerability scanner,
which lets you scan your builds
and ensure that the builds
you have are really secure.
KATHERINE MILLER: Great.
NIKHIL KAUL: But for
many organizations,
the process doesn't
even stop there.
What they need is a way to
have a policy set up as well.
For example, they want
a policy to ensure
that none of the builds which
have a security vulnerability
can ever be deployed
to production.
And that's why many
of the organizations
will use vulnerability scanner
with another tool which
we released at Next, which is
called Binary Authorization.
Using vulnerability
scanner and [INAUDIBLE]
Binary Authorization,
you can essentially
set up policies to decide
what gets deployed,
what doesn't get deployed.
Right now, we are seeing
only vulnerability scanner.
And as you can see, it
has found a vulnerability.
So the next step, obviously, is
to resolve the vulnerability.
So we resolve the
vulnerability by, again,
clicking the red button.
The vulnerability gets resolved.
And you can see the scan
being rerun over here.
So till this time in the
demo, we have created a build.
We have scanned
the vulnerability.
The next step, obviously,
is deploying the image.
Now, for deployment piece over
here, we are using Spinnaker.
You must be familiar
with Spinnaker,
since you work at Google.
So Spinnaker is an
open source tool,
which Google
contributes to, which
Google is a core
contributor to with Netflix.
Spinnaker makes the process of
creating deployment pipelines
across Cloud,
on-premise environments
really easy and simple.
So today, for the demo, we will
be deploying to, let's say,
Cloud.
On the screen, what
you see is actually
a blue-green deployment
taking place.
You will see Spinnaker going
through different stages
of the pipeline.
And as it goes through different
stages of the pipeline,
you will see the color
changing from blue to green.
For example, right now, it's
in the deploy new version
to Kubernetes image.
Now, it's in the last
image, where it's trying
to scale down previous parts.
And you will see the
color changing to green
as soon as the
deployment gets complete.
Right now, looks like
our app is deployed.
You can see the app over here.
And finally, you
get all the matrices
for building your app in
a continuous integration
and continuous delivery manner.
Any other questions
for me, Katie?
KATHERINE MILLER:
Well, I know that this
was a very simple and
efficient way to build an app.
But from what I understand, what
makes this helpful and useful
is that it does allow
teams to be much more
efficient and productive.
Is that correct?
NIKHIL KAUL: Absolutely.
One of the biggest things which
you will see, as a developer,
I would rather focus on writing
code rather than managing
infrastructure, especially
continuous integration
and continuous
delivery pipeline.
I want to get fast
feedback on my code.
I want to ensure what I
roll out to production
is of highest quality.
So all those things are being
built into this pipeline.
Developers are able
to focus on code.
Developers are able to get
fast feedback on code changes
through continuous integration.
And through things like
automated canary analysis,
which we have built
into Spinnaker,
you ensure that
what the code which
you're releasing to production
is of the highest quality
possible.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Well, thank you so much for
sharing this demo with us
and what makes it helpful
to our developers.
Enjoy the last
few hours of Next.
NIKHIL KAUL: You too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]